president serango whips thank you so
much for joining us here on the daily
climate show we really appreciate it
how is your country and its people
being affected by climate change right
now
well uh probably our biggest challenge
is that
before we didn't experience
storms
uh frequency of storms in the past year
we've had typhoons monsoons taken out
roads
destroyed homes
and uh being where we were located close
to the equator we weren't in the what we
call the typhoon belt
so
that's a direct uh result of
the change in climate
the other things that we see is uh the
rising sea levels so we have um in the
high tides now homes being flooded
um tarou's patches or we call them tarou
swamps where we get our food uh also
getting inundated with seawater
and
during the last typhoon why i was most
concerned because i said if
if it just
moved off course maybe another 15
degrees
it would be a direct
hit toward our hospital which would
bring in seawater and we could have lost
our hospital so those are real
challenges real threats that we face
each day but it doesn't just stop there
we also have impacts to our coral reefs
when we have droughts and severe uh
drought events we've lost that lost uh
reef habitats to core bleaching
uh we also see a reduced reduction in in
fish stock
uh because of the warming seas so those
are all challenges that we face each day
and
and maybe at
glasgow if you recall uh the term i used
is you might as well bomb us instead of
just having a suffer through this
uh
struggle that we face and that's why
it's so important
that we all
rise up to the challenge and really work
together
uh
to find innovative ways uh to solve the
climate crisis and the challenges that
we have
um if we could do it for covet
uh which you know i think uh we're
almost to the point where we can say
we're going to put covet behind us with
uh advances in vaccination and just
getting us prepared we should be able to
put the world together and get the world
together to
to focus on climate change and come up
with innovative and practical solutions
that we can all adapt
to mitigate the impacts
well yes and i'll talk a little bit
about the steps you're taking to try to
get some coordinated action but in the
meantime what are you doing to try to
adapt to the effects of climate change
and how are you paying for it
well you know i think one of the things
that at least we have done in palau is
we've taken an active role in preserving
our oceans we believe that
the ocean is the largest carbon sink
it's important for us to protect our
coral reefs so one of the initiatives
that was started many years ago was to
have a an area we call the protected
area network in palau
uh
and having reserved areas that we
we protect
uh the biodiversity but more important
those coral reefs are so important
for uh uh
protecting our oceans protecting our
fish
our corals and also serve as is as a
carbon sink for us
uh we've also uh gone to the uh our our
eez which is about the size of france
and made sure that uh we protect it and
and really
the the
what we've been looking at here in palau
is how do we use the oceans really to
improve the livelihoods of our people by
by using them sustainably by looking at
areas where we can develop aquaculture
to not only uh protect the
biodiversity but to provide provide a
healthy uh food source uh
the same thing on the high sea i mean
our oceans we've we've done a lot of
work to combat iu
so that we can really uh
manage those resources effectively but
at the same time provide
food supply food security to our islands
uh so that we take
uh less private reduce the pressure that
we have on the coral reefs by eating
pelagic fish and fish fish that are out
in the in the
deep sea
so
uh
those are just some of the initiatives
that we're doing in managing our oceans
and then on the out up land uh
you know we're doing a lot of work in
and preserving our our watersheds uh and
the forest that we have
uh palau uh is fortunate that we have a
large landmass and not a very big
population and we we believe that we're
a blessed and it is our responsibility
to protect them and develop it
sustainably uh
not only for the palauans but for the
world
so you face huge challenges because of
climate change and adapting to it is
expensive so were you reassured by what
was agreed at cop26 for example wealthy
countries there for example promised to
double adaptation finance for vulnerable
countries by 2025. do you feel that
progress is really being made
well you know i i know that it's it's
difficult um to make change
and but you know every little step
counts
but you know i think we need to
encourage um
our friends that said we need to start
taking bigger steps
and uh cop 26 was definitely a ray of
hope
that i think we're going in the right
direction
and you know i want to
thank france for being the first country
this year
to
to have the one ocean um
conferences summit in in france and and
we're hoping to continue that on in
palau with our oceans in april uh 13th
and 14th and of course uh on to lisbon
and i think what what we want to build
on is those commitments that were made
we need to increase the work whether
it's in marine pollution and
in protecting our seas iuu and and also
uh just
uh sustainably managing our our oceans
and really producing a sustainable blue
economy those are really the initiatives
that we need to work on together
and and and our our larger friends that
are making a bigger impact on climate
change need to step it up
and also contribute to the climate
mitigation and climate adaptation
and uh
where we're
we would like to see more and i think
that's why it's important that we have
these conferences and continue to push
the momentum forward because if we don't
as my friends uh from the marshall
islands and they had had me represent
them at the high level
uh ambition high ambition panel at
glasgow
said you know if we don't
turn this around at this conference
we're going under
and why should any country or any island
disappear
uh because
we didn't make the choices the hard
choices uh
to turn the tide around
uh
and i you know it's the same as saving
lives we've made big sacrifices
uh all of us around the world to protect
ourselves from coven and i think that's
the same
drive and initiative that we need from
all countries if we're gonna address
climate change
and
you know the glasgow gave us hope but
there's still a lot of work to be done
okay so what specifically do you need to
see agreed and acted on at cop27
well we've talked about um
climate adaptation climate mitigation
we've seen those commitments
but
we need to see tangible
that they really come out to the
communities and they really impact lives
you know a lot of it is um i have to say
has been talk
uh and
and then they've made it difficult for
us to access those funds and sometimes
made it difficult because they say well
we're
you're you're kind of not a small
developing or you're no longer at least
developing so maybe you can't access it
so those kinds of things if we're really
out there to help and help with the
mitigation and the impacts
and
and adaptation we need to make those
that financing accessible easily
accessible
and so it can really uh
make the impacts that it's intended to
do
but at the same time
we need those commitments that say you
know
if
if we're going to meet 1.5
we need we need to cut those emissions
ideally in half by 2030. we cannot wait
till 2050.
we need to start taking boulder action
sooner
and you've joined the commission of
small island states cosis on climate
change and international law to bring a
case uh to the un uh international
tribunal for the law of the sea so tell
us what you're trying to achieve with
that action and why you feel it's
necessary to take it
well at times i think
as as small islands
we see the change happening
we we suffer it every day
and and i think many times the action
the response
prima from the larger nascents is is a
little bit um
is behind it's it's not it's it's not
happening fast enough
so really the intent is to raise that
awareness and
to make people understand that the
choices that you make
every day impact the lives of people
around the world and especially small
island states so make the right choices
you know uh
bringing that action is to encourage
people to change
to make those commitments and
and to make the right decisions
so
hopefully
by saying
the large polluters pay
they will take responsibility
you don't have to pay you don't have to
pay if you make if you make those
changes
but uh we need them to make those
commitments and stick to them and act
more aggressively
so
well
you know a study has has been done and
we
we
are the least contributors but are
received the biggest impact on climate
change
and our voices need to be heard
and this is one way to let the world
know the challenges that we face and
hopefully
the voices can be heard and change can
happen
do you feel listened to is it hard to
feel listened to when you're such a
small nation just 18 thousand people
uh yes
uh we're small
and it's hard to find us on the map
and
and uh
and i think sometimes that that's why
we're we're
but you know one of the things that um
uh that's so important by these these
conferences and and these events it's
allowed us to raise that awareness raise
that voice
and uh you know we appreciate uh sky
news taking the time to reach out to us
and give us the opportunity to share the
challenges that we have on our small
islands uh so that the world knows that
there's we should not ever
live in a world where
we would have to go to textbooks or
history books to learn about these
islands and those cultures and those
people because they vanished because
of climate change
uh we don't want to ever see that
and and and i believe that this
generation
of
of the of the uh in the world can make a
difference and it really requires all
all of us working together
how worried though are you for the
future
well i'm worried but i have hope because
you know
uh
you have to be able to have hope and you
have to dream
the impossible and you know we've seen
the advances in technology i mean today
you know you're in
london i'm here in palau we can have
this conversation
uh i remember when i was going to
college and it was four dollars a minute
to go and be on a telephone call this
would not be possible
uh so
you know
change can happen
uh we just got to put our minds and we
have to be committed to it
and
i know that uh
if
uh the will is there it can be done and
i you know i have faith that people
around the world
generally want to do the right thing and
want to do the good thing
and
and i think that's really what we need
people around the world to understand
what the issues that we all face
and how we can solve these problems
together and people are
you know have good intentions but
sometimes it's a lack of information and
really
sky news and
uh you know these conferences help us
raise that awareness and hopefully
make people want to make the right
choices
about our future
president serango whips junior of palau
thanks very much indeed
thank you